i'd say all the goofing around at pam's
desk and
and hanging out with pam was finally
caught up to him
you know with pam
hey hey i got you one oh wow thank you
yeah i'm just gonna grab some chips you
want some
no thanks uh we're still having lunch
today right i guess
how dare you
hey toby what's this huh i just want to
remind everyone about the company rules
involving pda
or public displays of affection yes uh
some people in the office have
complained
oh without some other people engaging in
pda and
you know just want to remind it's not
appropriate to to do that
this is about me and jan in my office
because i will have you know that that
was consensual
what we did has nothing to do with you
or anyone here i don't think
anyone heard anything we were very
discreet
and and i most people had left by that
point so i don't
i don't think it's any of your business
so what i think you should do
is roll up the memo real tight okay hey
look the memo is not about
you for the record i have never been
involved with anyone at work in any
capacity
all right everyone look you all right
the complaint was
about jim and pam so
no way what you guys are together
um yep
yes we are wow wow
awesome to the two of you
yes yes toby was this your fun little
way of congratulating us
yes okay
hey this is not halfway
i did the math i had to drive way longer
than that
montclair would have been closer so you
have to buy lunch
what are you doing i just
i can't wait oh my god
[Music]
hey toby hey
you two hey so now that we are
dating uh we just wanted to know if we
had to sign one of those
we're dating things for the company oh
well
you know those were only for you know
relationships
so if it's just a casual thing there's
no need
really oh well i don't want to speak for
jim but
it's like pretty official
uh-huh
sorry so do we need to sign one or
let's just wait and see what happens
yeah
what let's just wait
oh okay okay great
did i ever tell you why i left scranton
yeah i didn't think i had well
it was all about pam
yeah i mean she was with roy
and uh i just couldn't take it
i mean i lost it dwight
i couldn't sleep i couldn't concentrate
on anything
and then weird stuff like food
had no taste
so my solution was to move away
it was awful
and it is something that i wouldn't wish
on my worst enemy
and that includes you
hey i was thinking about dinner we
uh dinner let's see maybe we should try
the um italian place where the dry
cleaners to be
okay yeah yeah okay
jim's just really passionate about
italian food
yeah i'm very passionate about italian
food
in fact um i'm in love with italian food
actually it's kind of too bad we're not
coming into work tomorrow
why i bet michael had some elaborate
theme party planned like scrambled eggs
saturday
i'm like hey everyone let's get your
boss late saturday
i have an announcement uh to make
i am moving to costa rica
thought about it for a long time now
and i'm finally gonna do it
so i'm just gonna hop the fence and jog
home now
you closed it i closed it yes
ah
um congratulations to you thank you oh
thank you very much
appreciate it well done thank you
you know what screw this
wow i'm gonna miss toby
he has a nice calming presence in the
office
[Music]
don't tell him i said this but i always
thought he was kind of cute
you